Speaker 1: All right, this is a wild story
that some people are actually finding themselves
sort of sort of triggered by.
There is a MSNBC TV analyst named Malcolm
Nance, and he's been around for a while now,
a former intelligence guy, kind of a well,
well known in the space at this point in time.
He has actually joined the fight in Ukraine.
He is.
He is fighting in Ukraine, at least to some
extent, against the Russian invasion.
And this is fascinating.
And without becoming sort of like a war pawn
advocate, this is someone putting their sort
of money or their time, at least where their
mouth is.
There's a report from The Denver Gazette.
MSNBC analyst Malcolm Nance reveals he joined
the fight in Ukraine.
Malcolm Nance, an author and former military
intelligence analyst, appeared for an interview
Monday with MSNBC host Joy Reid, who said
he was at a secure location.
Nance was dressed in military garb and holding
a rifle, said he joined Ukraine's foreign
legion about a month ago to fend off what
he called Russia's war of extermination.
I have a little bit of that interview.
Let's check it out and you will notice if
you're watching Malcolm Nance is wearing.
I don't want to use the wrong term.
I guess we'll just call it military garb,
and he's holding a weapon as well.
Speaker 2: Joining me now from a secure location
in western Ukraine is Malcolm Nance, executive
director of the Terror Isometrics project.
He's fighting with the International Legion
of Territorial Defense of Ukraine and Malcolm.
We just watched that video of you and Ali
RUSI was attempting to interview you for us
to get more information on what you're doing.
We saw those cruise missiles fly overhead.
So explain to us why you are there and what
you are doing.
Speaker 3: Well, as you know, I spent quite
a bit of time here in the pre-war period,
and when the invasion happened, I had friends
who were in Donetsk, who were in the Ukrainian
army, who were writing to us and telling us
We're not going to survive tonight.
We've been hit five hundred times.
You know, these are graduates of Defense Language
Institute.
These are my friends.
And you know, as the more I saw of the war
going on, the more I thought, I'm done talking.
All right, it's time to take action here.
So about a month ago, I joined the International
Legion here in Ukraine, and I am here to help
this country fight.
You know what essentially is a war of its
of extermination.
This is an existential war.
And Russia has bought it to these people and
they are mass murdering civilians.
And there are people here like me who are
here to do something about it.
Speaker 1: So there's some on the left who
have reacted to this by saying, Oh God, the
glorification of Malcolm Nance doing this
is war porn.
It's glorifying violence.
It's pro-war to say what a great thing that
Malcolm Nance is doing.
I don't see it that way.
Nance is sixty one.
He could just stay with his cushy MSNBC gig,
and I'm guessing he does consulting and speaking
and all these different things.
He is at least theoretically.
I mean, listen, you know, if you come back
and you tell me Nance isn't really exposed
to any danger, this is all a setup he put
on a uniform and he's there, but he's in like
the part of the country where nothing's going
on.
OK, well, I mean, like, listen, there's no
evidence of that, but I'm sure someone would
make that claim.
But at least in theory he is.
He's there and he's putting himself at risk.
And he believes that this is a war of aggression
by Russia against Ukraine, that Ukraine is
fighting a defensive war.
And along those lines, if you are in a position
to have to defend your country and by proxy,
that's what Malcolm Nance is doing.
You're not pro-war because you say, Wow, he's
actually in the real world doing the thing
that many of us just sit in front of microphones
and say, this is the side that I'm on for
lack of a better term.
So seeing this and saying that the other aspect
to this is there's a there's a big I don't
want to call it big.
There's a loud movement on the online left,
which is very just black and white, antagonistic
against any government or intelligence agency.
And they haven't liked Malcolm Nance for a
long time.
They say this guy is the epitome of the.
Sometimes they'll even use the term deep state
or of the establishment intel that got Iraq
wrong, and they got this wrong and they got
that wrong.
And so they see this as the sort of worst
of the worst meshing of American intelligence
and corporate media and pro-war Democrats
or whatever you want to say.
I really just don't see it that way.
I am as anti-war as anybody else.
This is a defensive war for Ukraine, and he
is at least to some degree, putting his money
where his mouth is.
It's not a glorification of war like a war
movie.
I just don't see it that way.
If you disagree and you think that is what
this Malcolm Nance thing is, then I want to
hear from you.